اهلا بكم الى النشره المفصله من العربيه
انا ميسون عزام احييكم مشاهدينا هذه
الخامسه ونبدا بالعناوين
جده تحتضن انطلاق اعمال القمه العربيه في
دورتها الثانيه والثلاثين بحضور عربي كامل
كما جرت العاده السوريه لا يمكن ان تغيب
عن اي قمه
المقبله
فرنسا تتحرك لحصار جماعه الاخوان تجميد
نحو 20 صندوقا ماليا تدعم تيارات اسلامي
ارهابيه
رئيس مجلس السياده السودانيه يظهر خارجيا
لاول مره منذ بدء الاشتباكات
اذا مشاهدينا سنبدا الخامسه من جده حيث
تسلمت السعوديه رئاسه الدوره 32 للقمه
العربيه من الجزائر طبعا رئيس الدوره
السابق رحب وزير خارجيه الجزائر احمد
عطابي تسليم السعوديه رئاسه الدوره
الحاليه دعونا نتابع
كم ان ادعوا اخي
سمول امير فيصل بن فرحان بن عبد الله ال
سعود وزير خارجيه المملكه العربيه
السعوديه الشقيقه
لتسلم رئاسه المجلس
متمنيا له كاملا نجاح
وتمام التوفيق في اداء مهامه
ومعربا له في ذات السياق عن دعمنا التام
لرئاسه المملكه وعن يقيننا انها ستشكل
محطه عامه
لتكريس اسس التفاعل والتوافق والوحده في
خدمه مشروعنا الجماعي
وهو مشروع حضاري بامتياز
كما رحب وزير الخارجيه الجزائري احمد
عطافي مستهل الاجتماع التحضيري لوزراء
الخارجيه العرب قبل القمه العربيه رحب
بعوده سوريا الى مقعدها في الجامعه
العربيه
ترحب الجزائر
ايما ترحيب
ببوادر تكريس هذا التوجه
الذي بدات تتجلى
ملامحه مع استئناف الجمهوريه العربيه
السوريه
الشقيقه شغله مقعدها بمنظمتنا
والخطوات التي تم اتخاذها
لتطوير
وتقويه العلاقات العربيه السوريه
والمساهمه بشكل جماعي في حل الازمه في هذا
البلد الشقيق فضلا عن التقارب الحاصل في
العلاقات العربيه مع الجارتين تركيا
وايران
وايضا في هذا الاطار رحب وزير الخارجيه
السعوديه الامير فيصل بن فرحان من جانبه
بمشاركه الوفد السوري في دوره القمه
العربيه 32 شدد الامير فيصل بن فرحان على
ضروره التوحد لمواجهه التحديات التي
يواجهها العالم نتابع
وانتهز هذه الفرصه للترحيب بمشاركه
الجمهوريه العربيه السوريه في اجتماعنا
اليوم اصحاب السوء والمعاني يمر عالمنا
اليوم بتحديات وصعوبات عديده تجعلنا امام
مفترق طرق تحتم علينا الوقوف صفا واحدا
وبذل المزيد من الجهد للتعزيز العمل
العربي المشترك من اجل مواجهتها وايجاد
الحلول المناسبه لها لتصبح منطقتنا امنه
ومستقره تنعم بالخير والرفاه ان منطقه
العربيه تسخر بطاقات بشريه وثروات طبيعيه
تجعلنا امام تحدي مع انفسنا يفرض علينا
جميعا التنسيق المستمر وتسخير كافه
الادوات الممكنه وتفعيل الابتكار الات عمل
الجديده نابدين خلافاتنا البينيه رافضين
التدخلات الخارجيه واضعين نصب اعيننا
مصالح دولنا وشعوبنا من اجل تحقيق نهضه
شامله طالما تطلعت اليها شعوبنا
طبعا هذه القمه القمه العربيه في دورتها
33 تتزامن مع عدد من الاحداث التي تشهدها
المنطقه العربيه منها الاشتباكات في
السودان ايضا عوده سوريا الى الجامعه
العربيه بالاضافه الى الاحداث في غزه
وغيرها السفير حسام زكي مساعد الامين
العام للجامعه العربيه قال ان الملف
السوداني سيتصدر ابرز الملفات المنتظره
على طاوله القاده العرب حيث تتواصل
الاجتماعيات على مستوى وزراء الخارجيه على
هامش القمه بهدف بحثي كيفيه التحرك قدما
لتحقيق وقف مستمر لاطلاق النار لفتل سفير
الى انه بالاضافه للسودان هناك ملفات
سياسيه مهمه وتاتي في مقدمتها في فلسطين
اضافه الى قضيه اعاده اعمار سوريا وعودتها
الى الجامعه العربيه بعد 12 عاما من
الغياب من الملفات المهمه ايضا اشار
السفير الى الاتفاق السعوديه الايراني
الذي تنتظر انعكاساته على الاستقرار في
المنطقه
الى ذلك اكد وزيره خارجيه مصر والسعوديه
وايضا امين عام الجامعه العربيه خلال
الاجتماع اجتماع حول السودان على هامش قمه
جده اكدوا على اهميه التوصل لوقف فوري
ومستدام لاطلاق النار حفاظا على مقدرات
الشعب السوداني بالاضافه الى اهميه
التعامل مع الازمه السودانيه باعتبارها
شانا داخليا
على كل المزيد معنا من داخل مقر
الاجتماعات وزراء الخارجيه العرب في جده
معنى مراسل العربيه عبد الرحمن العصيمي
اهلا بك عبد الرحمن اليك
انتهى قبل قليل اجتماع وزراء الخارجيه
العرب هذا الاجتماع الذي القى من خلاله
وزريخ خارجيه السعوديه والجزائر بالاضافه
الى الامين العام احمد ابو الغيط كلماتهم
الثلاث طبعا اذا ما اردنا ميسون معرفه
ملامح البيان الختامي لهذه القمه فهو
يتاتى من خلال الكلمات وايضا
التوصيات والمبادرات التي اتفق عليها
اليوم وزراء خارجيه العرب احمد ابو الغيط
تحدث عن ملفات مهمه عن ليبيا وسوريا
واليمن واكد بان الجمود الموجود حاليا في
بعض الملفات العربيه ربما يكون محفزا
لاتخاذ المزيد من الخطوات وتحريك المياه
الراكده ايضا تحدث عن اهميه التقارب
السعودي الايراني بالرعايه تحت رعايه
الصين وان هذا التقارب ربما ينعكس ايجابا
على المنطقه العربيه ايضا الملفت للنظر
ميسون هو حجم الوفد السوري المشارك في
اجتماع وزراء خارجيه العرب وزير الخارجيه
السوري اتى وبرفقته ثمانيه مسؤولين على
مستوى عالي في وزارته بالاضافه طبعا الى
مندوب الدائم لدى الامم المتحده وعدد من
المسؤولين ايضا
المصادر اكدت بان الرئيس السوري بشار
الاسد سيكون حاضرا في هذه القمه رفقه عدد
ايضا لا باس به من المسؤولين السوريين على
راسهم طبعا وزير الخارجيه فيصل المقداد
بالاضافه طبعا الى
مستشاره الرئيس بثينه شعبان عدد من
المسؤولين الكبار في سوريا ايضا عبد
الرحمن ايضا تعليق قبل ان نكمل قبل ان
نكمل بالنقاط الاخرى فقط فيما يتعلق
بسوريا تحديدا لانه في ترحيب كبير في
كلمات على كل ابقى معنا عبد الرحمن ربما
اليك ولكن مضطره ان انتقل الان الى جلسه
لمجلس الامن حول اليمن نستمع تقارير
مستمره عن العنف عبر خطوط التماسلسيه ما
في الجوف تعز مارب وساده
تؤكد على هشاشه الوضع الراهن وعلى ضروره
التوصل الى وقف رسميا لاطلاق النار
ويقلقني كذلك التدهور في الوضع الاقتصادي
والقيود المفروض على حريه الحركه وتاثيرها
على النشاط الاقتصادي وعلى حياه السكان
ومصادر رزقهم ان عدم قدره حكومه اليمن
تصدير النفط الذي يولد اكثر من نصف
العائدات الحكوميه وولد اكثر من نصف
العائدات الحكوميه العام الماضي يقيد قدره
الحكومه على الايفاء بموجباتها ازاء شعب
اليمن وان السياسات الاقتصاديه والماليه
غير المتصقه في مختلف مناطق البلاد القت
بعبئها على المواطنين والشركات والشركات
تعيش اليوم في انعدام يقين في صنعاء وفي
المحافظات المجاوره
غياب التعاون بين الاطراف بشان المسائل
النقديه والماليه الرئيسيه يعني ان هذه
التحديات ستتفاقم وستزداد عمقا بالرغم من
كل هذه التحديات العميقه ثمه مجال للتفاؤل
الحذر في الاسابيع الاخيره اعتمد الاطراف
بعض الخطوات الايجابيه الاضافيه وعلى اثر
اطلاق
800 محتاجه الشهر الماضي بتيسير من المكتب
ولجنه الدوليه للصليب الاحمر ودعم من
حكومه سويسرا
من المملكه العربيه السعوديه اطلق انصار
الله
مجموعه اضافيه من المحتجزين وانا واثقه من
ان اطلاق سراحي هؤلاء سوف يوفروا بيئه
مؤديه للحوار ولكن مع كل عمليه اطلاق
وفي حين ان هذه تعتبر ايجابيه للموقفين
واسرهم هناك الالاف الذين ما زالوا في
الاحتياجات لذلك ادعوا الاطراف الى
الاستمرار بالعمل مع مكتب للايفاء
بواجباتهم للافراج عن كل المحتجزين وفقا
لاتفاق ستوكه
منذ اسبوعين تماما وفي الثالث من عيار
مايو احتفلنا بالذكرى الثلاثين لليوم
العالمي لحريه الصحافه وفي حين ان الافراج
الاخير عن اربع صحفيين كجزء من اتفاقي
اطلاق سراح المحتجئين يعتبر خطوه ايجابيه
ما زال
الناشطون في مجال الاعلام في اليمن
يواجهون التهديد والمضايقه والسجن ومصادره
مكاتبهم وممتلكاتهم ادعوا كل الاطراف
بموجب القانون الدولي الى الافراج عن كل
المحتجزين تعسفيا بما في ذلك الصحفيين
ومناصر حقوق الانسان
والمعارضين السياسيين وكل المدنيين
المحتجزين تعسفيا السيده الرئيسه
ان اساس اي اتفاق حول السبيل قدما يجب ان
يكون استئناف العمليه السياسيه بقياده
يمنيه برعايه الامم المتحده لانهاء النزاع
الصعوبات التي وصفتها للتو بالاضافه الى
طائفه تحديات الاخرى التي يواجهها اليمن
يمكن ان تعالج لا يمكن ان تعالج من خلال
حلول مؤقته او جزئيه
وحدها عمليه سياسيه شامله وجامعه يمكن ان
توصل الى شراكه سياسيه جديده وان تضمن
مستقبلا امنا ومستقرا اقتصاديا يمكن فيه
لمؤسسات الدوله ان تعمل بفعاليه وان تعود
اليمن الى علاقات سلميه مع جيرانهم هذه
العمليه السياسيه يجب ان تعالج مواضيع
الشائكه على المدى الطويل ويتعين مع ان
تبدا باقرب فرصه ممكنه وان الطابع الجامع
لهذه العمليه جوهري لضمان استدامه اي حل
سياسي
الحوار الذي اجري مؤخرا بين عدد من
المجموعات السياسيه الجنوبيه في عدن يؤكد
مجددا على ضروره ان يناقش اليمنيون جماعيا
مستقبلهم وان يتفقوا عليهم من خلال عمليه
بقياده يمنيه ودعم اممي في هذه العمليه
لابد من سماع صوت كل اليمنيين ونؤكد كذلك
على اهميه مشاركه النساء والشباب في كافه
نواحي عمليه السلام وفقا لقرار مجلس الامن
1325 واشراك المجتمع المدني كذلك ان
المشاركه المجديه والفعاله لا تقتصر فقط
على عدد النساء وممثل المجتمع المدني
المشاركين ولكن انها تشمل كذلك اتاحه حيزا
للنساء والمجتمع المدني لمعالجه اولوياتهم
والمساهمه بخبراتهم ومعارفهم فالمراه
والمجتمع المدني غالبا ما يتم اسكاتهما
السيده الرئيسه اود ان اختنمها فرصه لاعيد
التاكيد عن تقدير للدعم هذا المجلس الثابت
فان عمل المجلس ووحدته حول اليمن امر نرحب
به وان دعمكم المستمر ومرافقتكم لاي اتفاق
يتم التوصل اليه سيكتسب اهميه اكبر ليس
فقط على المدى القصير بل على المدى الطويل
ايضا يعمل اليمن على رسم مستقبل سلميا
وزاهر يستجيب الى طموحات شعب اليمن شكرا
على حسن الاسواق
اشكر السيد مشاهدينا سنكتفي بهذه الاحاطه
من المبعوث الخاصه الى اليمن طبعا تحدث
فيها بانجاز عن التطورات فيما يتعلق
بالتعاطي مع الحوثيين وايضا الوضع في داخل
اليمن نكمل ونعود الى القمه العربيه وزير
الخارجيه السوري فيصل المقداد قال على
هامش حضوره الاجتماعات طبعا التحضيريه
للقمه العربيه التي تحتضنها السعوديه قال
انه التقى مع نظيره في حكومه تصريف
الاعمال اللبنانيه عبد الله بو حبيب وشددا
على ضروره عوده جميع النازحين السوريين
الى بلادهم
وقد رحب الامين العام لجامعه الدول
العربيه احمد ابو الغيط بمشاركه وزير
الخارجيه السوري في اجتماعي وزراء خارجيه
العرب كما رحب بعوده سوريا الاجتماعات
القمه العربيه مشيرا الى انه يتطلع لتفاعل
سوري بناء وايجابيا
رحبوا في مجلسنا بالدكتور العزيز الصديق
فيصل المقداد وزير خارجيه الجمهوريه
العربيه السوريه
واتمنى ان تكون استعاده سوريا لمقعدها
مقدمه لانهاء ازمتها
والاستعادتها لحيويتها وحضورها في العمل
العربي ابن سوريا دوله لها اسهام حضاري
بارز في هذه المنطقه على مر تاريخها وهي
دوله مؤسسه مؤسسه في هذه الجامعه
واننا جميعا نتطلع لتفاعل سوري بناء
وايجابي مع هذه الحراك العربي لصالح شعبها
وتعزيزا لدورها وحضورها
وزير الخارجيه السوري فيصل المقداد في
تصريحات للعربيه قال وذلك طبعا بعد
الاجتماع التحضيري قال قبل القمه العربيه
ان سوريا لا يمكن ان تغيب عن اي قمه عربيه
نحن سنرحب باي دور ستقوم به الدول العربيه
في هذا المجال
كما جرت العاده السوريه لا يمكن ان تغيب
عن اي قمه
كما قلت لا يمكن لسوريه ان تغيب عن اي قمه
والمزيد معنا من القاهره اشرف العشريه
الكاتب الصحفي ومدير تحرير صحيفه الاهرام
اهلا بك استاذ اشرف اسمح لي ان ابدا
بسوريا وحضورها الان هناك ترحيب استمعناه
بالكلمات ان كان من الدوله المضيفه او ان
كان من الامانه العامه للجامعه العربيه
ولكن هل بالفعل يمكن ان نقول انه هذا
الترحيب سينعكس على طبيعه العلاقات ما بين
الدول العربيه وسوريا
مساء الخير ست ميسون بكل تاكيد اعتقد
سوريا ستكون عروسه هذا لهذه القمه لا تنسي
ان هناك
وربما سيكون هناك بالفعل اتكلم بشار الاسد
في هذه القمه يشكر فيها الدول العربيه
التي ساعدت على مدار عامين الماضيين خلف
الكواليس لعوره سوريا وايضا ان نعيش هذه
اللحظه فيما يتعلق بالاحتفاء بسوريا بعد
قرار الجامعه العربيه في السابع من مايو
في الجامعه العربيه في السبع من كل تاكيد
ستلعب دورا كبيرا في هذه العوده من خلال
ان هناك تفاعل عربي عربي وحراك عربي
باتجاه توفير الغطاء والدعم لسوريا في
المرحله القادمه لا تنسى ان هذه العوده
الميمونه استغرقت عامين او اكثر خلف
الكواليس بشكل معين غير معلن واجتماعات
حتى بلغت شرواتها في اجتماعات شهر رمضان
الماضي ثم انعكست في اجتماع ايضا الاجتماع
الخاص بالاردن في عمان ثم كانت قرار القمه
قرار الخارجيه العرب
التي يرحب بها كما نشاهد من خلال هذه
الكلمات ولكن ايضا اذا ما قرانا بتفاصيل
الكلمات الامانه العامه قال ابو الغيط
بانه يتطلع لتفاعل سوري بناء وايجابي
تحدثت كثيرا عن قضيه الغطاء العربي وما
يمكن للعرب ان يقدموه الان من دعم لسوريا
ماذا عن سوريا ما الذي يمكن ان تقدمه بهذه
الفتره او على الاقل مطلوب منها
بكل تاكيد هناك استراتيجيه تم التوافق
عليها من خلال لائحه مطالب تم التوسع
اليها في لقاء جده ثم في لقاء الاردن
تحديدا خمس مطالب رئيسيه وجوهريه تم
التوافق وسوريا من خلال فيصل المقدار في
اجتماع عمان قدم كثير من المواقف
الايجابيه لحد ما من قبل قياده تتماشى
بشكل تدريجي مع المطالب العربيه ابرزها ما
يعرف بتوفيق توفير غطاء او حضور عربي في
اي تسويه سياسيه في المرحله القادمه لان
الجانب العربي والعطف في العربيه قررت هذه
المره اخذ ممن مبادره بالحضور والمشاركه
العربيه في اي اجتماعات دوليه خاصه
بالازمه السوريه بين المعارضه وبين النظام
بما فيها اجتماعات جينيف سوتشي الستانه
بالاضافه الى حل قريه المعتقلين والسجناء
وضع خريطه وضع خريطه الطريق الافراج عنهم
وقف عمليه التهريبون وغيرها من الحضور
السوريه باتجاه الاراضي الاردن واسماكه
العربيه السعوديه والخليج ان يكون هناك
بالفعل ايضا بدء خريطه او التزام سوري
بعوره اللاجئين ووجدنا وزير خارجيه
السوريه يجتمع
اللبناني ابو حبيب ويتم التوافق على وضع
جدول لعوره اللاجئين السوريين وايضا
النازحين الاراضي السوريه ارى ان ما قدمته
سوريا هو الذي شجع الاطراف العربيه او
السته الماضيه وسرقت العربيه
بكل تاكيد وهذا الامر سينعكس اجابه على
مرحله القادمه في قريتين عاده الاعمار
سيخرج بيان او مقتن القمه العربيه بشان
حاله الاعمار وايضا بشان ما يتعلق بعجل
دوران التسويه العربيه تسويه السوريه من
خلال طرح وحضور عربي طاغي في مرحله
القادمه بعد ان علم العرب انهم اختفوا
عشترك الاطراف اقليميه ودولية
ماذا يعني بالنسبه لهذه القمه والقرارات
التي يمكن ان تتخذ
صراحه بعد اقسم 30 عاما في متابعته القيمه
العربيه من خلال عملي في الاهرام هذه
القمه بعيد عن مصطلحات التقليديه قمه
استثنائيه تاتي في اجواء ايجابيه غير
مسبوقه منذ عام 2011 بعد احداث او الثورات
ب 2011 كان هناك تشابكات وتعقيدات وكثير
من التشرزم والخلل والتباعد في المواقف
العربيه وهناك اقطار عربيه اصابها كثير من
الزلزال السياسي والامني حتى السنوات
الماضيه نحن الان ذاهبين الى قمه جده
التعويل على النجاح السياسي والاقتصادي
والحضور السعودي الدبلوماسي والسياسي في
الاقليم وفي المنطقه سينعكس ايجابا وربما
يكون هناك هذه قمه التجديد والتغيير اي
تجديد العهد على المصطلحات عربيه ولم
الشمل تغيير نحو افق ابرز فيما يتعلق
بالتعاطف مع الملفات الاقتصاديه اولا التي
سوف تحظى على درجه كبيره من امنيه في هذه
القمه وايضا امكانيه ان يكون نقش ردم هو
الخلافات العربيه والبحث في حلول عربيه
لازمات عربيه السودان سيكون في المقدمه
منها بالطبع وهذه النقطه الرئيسيه يعني
يقال من خلال التصريحات بانه السود
ان سوداني سوداني بمعنى اخر لا تدخل
لا تدخل لاطراف دول الجوار الافريقيه او
حتى على المستوى الاممي بعد ان فشلوا على
مدار اكثر من شهر حتى هذه اللحظه هناك
تفاعل عربي عربي تم في اجتماعات مجلس
الجامعه العربيه في السابع من مايو تشكيل
لجنه تواصل عربي مكونه من المملكه العربيه
السعوديه ومصر
اليوم سيتم بلوره وتجديد وتقديم اليه
للقاعده العرب اعتقد الوزاره الخارجيه
العرب وافقوا عليها في اجتماع المغلق جلسه
المغلقه سترفع للقاده العرب لا تنسي ان
هناك رغبه في امكانيه المضي قدما نحو
تصفيه باكيات الخلافات الاستوديونيه
السودانيه بعد اجتماعات جده على مدار عشره
ايام الماضيه والتوسط الى ما يعرف باتفاق
المبدئي اعلان المبادئ اولا الاولي بوقف
اطلاق النار وتسهيل المساعدات وايضا اغاثه
اللاجئين وممرات صحيه وامنيه اعط قطعنا
نصف الطريق نحو امكانيه الوصول الى تسويه
النصف بقى سوف يتوقف على طرح مباطره عربيه
رشيده او ذكيه تلعب دورا كبيرا في امكانيه
اقناع الطرفين على مستوى الاطراف الرئيسيه
او القيادات
القاهره اشرف العشريه الكاتب الصحفي ومدير
تحرير صحيفه الاهرام شكرا جزيلا لك
ولكن بعد قليل
حزب كلتش دار جلو يكشف عن الاف المخالفات
في صناديق الاقتراع الانتخابات الرئاسيه
والبرلمانيه
اهلا بكم مجددا الى الخامسه قالت صحيفه
الفرنسيه ان فرنسا تضيق الخناق على جماعه
الاخوان الصحيفه اكدت ان فرنسا تضرب
الجماعه على المستوى المالي المرتبط
بالجمعيات التابعه لها الصحيفه اضافت ان
حوالي 20 صندوق تابع لاوقاف وتبرعات تم
تحديدها باعتبارها مشكوكا بارتباطها بتيار
متطرف في فرنسا وقد تقرر تجميد ما يقرب من
25 مليون يورو في مختلف صناديق الهبات
التابعه للاخوان في البلاد اشارت الصحيفه
الى ان هذه الاموال تم استثمارها بشكل غير
قانوني لضمان تشغيلي وصيانه المساجد
والمنظمات المعروفه بقربها من الجماعه
المزيد معنا من فريسه الصحفي والمحلل
السياسي محمد كلاش اهلا بك سيد محمد
اسمحلي انا ابدا بقراءه بهذه التحركات
الفرنسيه تاتي من ضمن حربها
المستمره على التطرف على الارهاب على
التنظيم نفسه ام انه في مخاوف محدده
داخليه فرنسيه تريد الحد منها للحفاظ على
قيم الجمهوريه كما يقولون
يعني بدايه ممكن القول باختصار بان فرنسا
كما كل اوروبا في اوروبا موضوع الاخوان
المسلمين بشكل محدد
والحاله الاسلاميه المتطرفه بشكل عام موضع
اهتمام كبير موضع مراقبه شديده موضع
ملاحقه شديده وما والحاصل هو نتيجه كل ذلك
نحن نعلم انه من بعد التفجيرات التي
حصلت في فرنسا في عام 2015 كان هناك
اجراءات امنيه ذات الطابع الامني طغى على
الطابع السياسي وذلك
لشده او لحده هذه التفجيرات والعدد الكبير
من الضحايا الذين سقطوا فيها لكن حاليا
التركيز اكثر طبعا مع الحفاظ على الشق
الامني التركيز اكثر على الشق السياسي على
التطرف السياسي على الكراهيه
في الخطاب الديني
واكثر لماذا هذا التحول اسمح لي فيما
يتعلق بالجانب الامني اولا ومن ثم التحول
الان اكثر على التركيز على الجانب السياسي
هل فرنسا تلمست بالفتره الاخيره خطاب جديد
من نوع جديد او تحركات وانشطه لهذا
التنظيم مختلفه
هناك فعل ليس هناك خطاب هناك فعل نتيجه
هذا الخطاب وهو قتل استاذ التاريخ
والجغرافيا صامويل
قبل سنتين ونصف لدى خروجه من المدرسه قطع
راسه من هنا كان التجديد ومن هنا كان حرص
السلطات الفرنسيه على الاهتمام بالخطاب
خطاب خطاب الكراهيه خطاب خطاب الديني في
الطابع ذو الطابع الذي يحمل كراهيه للمراه
يحمل للقيم للقيم الغربيه قيم الحريه قيم
الديمقراطيه الى الى ما هنالك
طبعا على هذا هذه النقطه ولكن هل لدينا
معلومات عن خلفيات هؤلاء وان كان فرنسا
تنظر لديهم على اساس انهم او ان هناك نوع
من العلاقه ما بينهم ودول بالخارج نحن
نعلم انه بفتره من الفترات فرنسا اوقفت
عدد من ائمه وربما رحلت ايضا اخرين
نعم رحله فرنسا رحلت كان اخر مره حالته
الامام امام مغربي قبل نحو خمسه اشهر لكن
فرنسا هناك تعاون ما بين فرنسا وعدد كبير
من الدول دول العالم في هذا الموضوع
وبات من المؤكد وهذه ليست
معلومه حصريه يعني معروفا ان دول عده كانت
تقدم مساعدات ماليه
لمن هم مجتبى بهم بانهم من الاخوان
المسلمين توقفت هذه الدول عن تقديم هذه
المساعدات منذ سنتين ونصف السنه تقريبا
هناك تعاون ما بين فرنسا ودول عده في هذا
الخصوص وايضا على المستوى الداخلي
المساعدات التي تقدمها الدوله تقدمها
المحافظه لجمعيات هم ابناء هذه المحافظه
جمعيات اجتماعيه وطبعا الغالب فيها لهذه
الجمعيه هناك
بنيه دينيه مستتره تستفيد منها هذه
الجمعيه وتطور خطابها الديني حرا وقد يخرج
من هذه الجمعيه خليه او اكثر وتذهب هذه
الخليه في مجال التطرف وهذه النقطه
الرئيسيه ما الذي تخافه الان ماذا نتوقع
من رد فعل لهذه الجماعه بعد هذه او هذا
الحصار اذا ما صح التعبير المالي
طبعا هذه الجماعات بشكل عام يعني موجوده
في كل فرنسا من شمال فرنسا الى جنوبها من
شرقها الى غربها موجوده
باعداد كبيره
وهي تنشط عاده في المدن في في الضواحي حيث
حيث تعتمد على شباب او فتيان تقريبا لم لم
يصلوا الى ما يفترض ان يصلوا اليه من تقدم
في حياتهم العمليه وحياتهم الاقتصاديه
عاده هؤلاء يرتكزون اكثر ما يرتكزون على
الاحزاب اليساريه المتطرفه ويقدمون انفسهم
على انهم ضحايا ما يسمونه باسلامه وفوبيا
الدوله
وتحتضنهم بشكل خاص الاحزاب اليساريه
المتطرفه هذا الامر بات معروفا طبعا تحت
اسم كرامه المواطن حريه المواطن وان
تبالغ في محاصره هؤلاء الى ما هنالك وطبعا
اليسار المتطرف يستفيد منهم في موضوع
الوصول الى
النجاح في الانتخابات وهؤلاء هم ذاتهم
ممكن ان يخترقوا البنيه السياسيه ويصل على
مستوى الجمعيات على مستوى
البلديات وايضا على مستوى الاحزاب
السياسيه الفاعله في مناطقهم وحاملين معهم
ايضا خطابهم السياسي صحيح
ظهر رئيس مجلس السياده السودانيه عبد
الفتاح البرهان وسطى عدد من جنود القوات
المسلحه امام مقر قياده القوات البريه في
الخرطوم طبعا هذا احدث ظهور للرئيس
السوداني منذ بدء الاشتباكات مع قوات
الدعم السريع يذكر ان مبنى قياده القوات
البريه يقع بمحيط مطار الخرطوم دعونا
نتابع
[موسيقى]
الله اكبر الله اكبر الله اكبر الله اكبر
الله اكبر الله اكبر الله اكبر الله
اكبر
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
الله اكبر
[موسيقى]
الله اكبر الله اكبر
الله اكبر الله اكبر الله اكبر الله اكبر
[تصفيق]
ابو شيبه اهلا بك عمار دعنا نبدا بهذا
الظهور الاول الموقع واهميته طبيعه
الرساله التي نقراها من خروجه
اهلا بك يا ميسون واهلا بالمشاهدين الكرام
نعم هذا هو الظهور الاول للقائد العام
للجيش السيد عبد الفتاح البرهان في محيط
مطار الخرطوم والقياده العامه والجيش وسط
عدد كبير من الجنود وهذه المنطقه وهنا
فيها اشاره هي منطقه القوات البريه
البرهان كان قائدا سابقا للقوات البريه
قبل ان ياتي في ابريل من العام رئيسا
للمجلس العسكري ومن ثم المجلس السيادي بعد
توقيع
الاتفاق حول الحكومه الانتقاليه والفتره
الانتقاليه هذا الظهور له عده مدلولات
واضحه من خلال انه
ظهر بشكل واضح بلباسه العسكري وحتى سلاحه
الشخصي وسط الجنود وايضا ياتي بالتزامن مع
عده معارك بالامس كانت عنيفه جدا في منطقه
شمال بحري وايضا كذلك في وسط العاصمه
الخرطوم ياتي هذا الظهور في اوقات كثيره
جدا هنالك كانت عده تساؤلات حول ظهور
السيد البرهان وقيادته المعركه من ارض
الميدان هذه الاشاره الاخرى ايضا بان
البرهان متواجد داخل المعركه وانه يستطيع
التحرك بكامل ربما العتاد وبكامل جنوده في
هذه المنطقه يؤشر ايضا الى ان اصبح القائد
العام الان يتحرك بشكل واضح في هذه
المنطقه التي دارت فيها اشتباكات عنيفه
منذ اليوم الاول للحرب خاصه وان عدد من
المعلومات التي سربت كانت تشير الى ان
قوات الدعم السريع حينما دخلت الى بيت
الضيافه مكان اقامه البرهان دارت معارك
عنيفه جدا في هذه المنطقه وان البرهان قد
خرج الى مكان اخر اكثر امنا داخل القياده
العامه للجيش ايضا هذا ياتي بالتزامن بان
قائد الدعم السريع كان قد ظهر في فيديو له
في اول ايام الحرب من داخل القصر الرئاسي
ايضا بلباسي العسكري وسلاحه الشخصي في
منطقه القصر الرئاسي الان البرهان يظهر
بشكل واضح ويقود هذه المعركه من داخل
القياده العامه للجيش هذا ايضا قد يذهب
بالكثيرين الى ان قد تكون هنالك ربما ظهور
القيادات اخرى في ارض الميدان لرفع الروح
المعنويه بشكل واضح ولقياده المعارك خاصه
وانها دخلت الى شهرها الثاني بشكل يبدو
انه متصاعد هذا الظهور ميسون ايضا يدل
بشكل واضح بان القياده الميدانيه للجيش
الان اصبحت تتحرك في محيط القياده العامه
للجيش بعد ان كانت هذه المنطقه منطقه
اشتباكات وربما ان الجيش استطاع وبنسبه
كبيره من خلال هذا الظهور ايضا ان يؤكد
بانه استطاع فك الخناق على القياده العامه
للجيش ما يعني ان هنالك تطورا ميدانيا
وتكتيكيا على الارض من خلال هذا الظهور
ايضا له عده قراءات اخرى
نعم له عده قراءات اخرى خاصه نعم خاصه وان
هنالك كان اجتماعنا اليوم في جده لبوزراء
الخارجيه العرب خاصه السعوديه ومصر واكدوا
على ضروره وقف اطلاق النار
في السودان واعتبار ان ما يجري في السودان
هو شانا داخليا يبدو ان هنالك متغيرات
عسكريه وايضا متغيرات سياسيه قد نلاحظها
او نشهدها في السعاده
في عمار ابو شيبه شكرا جزيلا لك
ومن السودان الى ليبيا فبعد قرار ايقاف
فتحي باش اغا من رئاسه الحكومه المكلفه من
البرلمان الليبي وايضا التحقيق معه اوضح
المتحدث الرسمي باسم مجلس النواب الليبي
عبد الله بلاحق اكد ان حكومه باشاغه فشلت
في الوفاء بتعهداتها على راسها دخول
العاصمه طرابلس نست
مع قرر مجلس النواب
ايقاف السيد رئيس الحكومه سيد فتحي باش
اغا واحالته للتحقيق
وتكليف السيد وزير الماليه الدكتور اسامه
حماد بمهام رئاسه الحكومه الى حين انتهاء
التحقيقات في مع السيد رئيس الحكومه الامر
متعلق بعدم الوفاء بتعهداتها وتعهدات
السيد رئيس الحكومه في مقدمتها تعهداته
بعمل الحكومه من داخل العاصمه طرابلس
ودخول العاصمه طرابلس وهذا اول تعهد لم
تفي به الحكومه او لم يتحقق ايضا عدم
تحقيق البرامج التي تعاهدت الحكومه بها
فبالتالي هذه هي
النقاط التي ادت الى ايقاف السيد رئيس
الحكومه
ونكمل الخامسه من تركيا حيث كشف محرم
اركيت نائب رئيس حزب الشعب الجمهوري
التركي طبعا الذي يقود المرشح الرئاسي
كمال كليتشار اوغلو كشف انه تم رصد مخالفه
في
2269 صندوقا للاقتراع خلال عمليه التصويت
في الانتخابات الرئاسيه بالاضافه الى
اربعه الاف وثمانمائه وخمسه وعشرين صندوقا
في الانتخابات البرلمانيه اضاف اركيك ان
حزبه يتتبع كل الاصوات التي تم الادلاء
بها حتى وان لم تتغير النتيجه
في الخامسه ولكن بعد قليل
رئيس الشركه المنتجه لتشات جي بي تي يحذر
من مخاطر الذكاء الاصطناعي على البشريه
اهلا بكم مجددا الى الخامسه تشاد جي بي تي
الاداه المجانيه التي يمكنها كتابه
المقالات والقصائد وحتى التخطيط للاجازات
بالطريقه ذاتها التي يفعلها الانسان طبعا
خلقت سؤال كبير حول الذكاء الاصطناعي بشكل
عام هل يضر بالبشريه اكثر مما ينفعها
سمويل التمان وهو رئيس شركه اوبن اي اي
للذكاء الاصطناعي والتي
صنعتيه قال خلال افادته امام الكونجرس
الامريكيه ان فوائد هذا التطبيق الجديد
تفوق المخاطر حتى الان محذرا من تغير
الحال اذا لم تتم مراقبته في حين يلعب
الذكاء الاصطناعي دورا كبيرا في تطوير بعض
المجالات كالطب مكافحه ايضا ازمات المناخ
التمن شدده على اهميه تشكيل وكاله امريكيه
او ربما عالميه ترخص انظمه الذكاء
الاصطناعي على ان تتمتع بسلطه سحب هذا
وضمان الامتثالي معايير السلامه راى اوت
من انه على هذه الوكاله التنظيميه الجديده
فرد ضمانات لتنظيم عمل نماذج الذكاء
الاصطناعي التي يمكنها التكرار والتسلل
الذاتي في اشاره طبعا ربما الى اسوا
المخاوف المستقبليه تجاه تلك الانظمه
المتقدمه والتي يمكن ان تتلافى بالبشر
وايضا تسيطر عليهم على كل المزيد معنا من
عمان الخبير في امن المعلومات رائد سمور
اهلا بك استاذ رائد وخلينا نبدا بالموقف
بما يتعلق بالفوائد مقارنه بالمخاطر هل
تؤيد فكره انه الفوائد حتى الان
تفوق المخاطر فيما يتعلق بهذا التطبيق
تحديدا
انا على مستوى رايي الشخصي لا انا اعتقد
انه ما دام لا يوجد تشريعات وقوانين ناظمه
لهذا العمل انا اعتقد انه المخاطر تفوق
الفوائد من هذا العمل
يعني حقيقه ما دام منها
قبل ان ندخل في الطبيعه طبيعه الحلول
خلينا نشوف المشكله وين بتقع
صحيح صحيح الاحلال الوظيفي في البدايه هذا
هذا خطر اول المخاطر الماء الخطر الثاني
اللي هو دخول الى منطقه الانسنه الانسانيه
بمعنى الدخول الى بهذا الذكاء الاصطناعي
والولوج الى مراحل الشعور الانساني هذه
الخطر الثاني الخطر الثالث وهو الاعم
والاجمل اعتقد اللي هو عسكره هذا الذكاء
واستخدامه من خلال العمليات العسكريه او
من خلال الاجهزه او اسلحه متطوره تعمل من
خلال الذكاء الاصطناعي بالتالي الجندي
الروبوت الذي يتم التحكم فيه من خلال
الذكاء الاصطناعي هو الان موجود لكن كما
تحدث في بدايه حديثي لا يوجد هناك اي نوع
من انواع
الضوابط القانونيه والاخلاقيه لمثل هذه
العمليات وبالتالي
تم مستمر هذا التطور الذي لا يمكن ان
يتوقف
هذه
اي نوع من الضوابط انا اعتقد انه نعم
المخاطر دوما
[موسيقى]
سيد رائد هل تسمعني
استاذ طيب لا يسمعني على كل نشكره على هذه
الاضافه من عمان الخبير في امن المعلومات
رائد سمور شكرا ونعتذر لهذه المشكله
التقنيه
شكرا محمد قيدت محكمه استئناف فرنسيه
ادانت الرئيس الفرنسي السابق
نيكولاساركوزيفي قضيه فساد محكمه
الاستئناف الفرنسيه ايدت المنع المؤقت
لسركزي من شغله وظائف عامه وكذلك حكمها
على الرئيس الفرنسي السابق لمده ثلاثه
سنوات اثنتان منها مع وقف التنفيذ اضافت
المحكمه في قرارها ان الرئيس الفرنسي
السابق سيضع سوارا الكترونيا بدلا من
احتجازه في السجن
تفقد زعيم كوريا الشماليه
اول قمر صناعي للاستطلاع العسكري لبلاده
وافق على خطط العمل المستقبليه للجنه
التحضيريه لاطلاق القمر وفقا لما ذكرته
وكاله الانباء المركزيه الكوريه الرسميه
جونغ اون اكد على الطبيعه الاستراتيجيه
لامتلاك اقمار الصناعيه للاستطلاع العسكري
وقال ان لبلاده الحق في الدفاع عن النفس
ضد تصعدي واشنطن وسيول
تشارك السعوديه في مهرجان كان السينمائي
بدورته السادسه والسبعين وتستقبل الخيمه
السعوديه نجوم وايضا صناع السينما
العالميه لتوقيع الاتفاقيات بين الشركات
العالميه المنتجه للافلام نتابع
[موسيقى]
وفد سينمائي كبير وتشارك به السعوديه في
مهرجان كان السينمائي بدورته السادسه
والسبعين حيث شارك نجوم العالم في العرض
الاول لفيلم الافتتاح جندي للمخرج الفرنسي
وبطوله النجم الامريكي وهو من انتاج
للمملكه العربيه السعوديه هو فرنسا طبعا
احنا اليوم في مهرجان كان
وطبعا امس شاهدنا اول اشتراك انتاجي من
صندوق البحر الاحمر
لفيلم فرنسي جانباري فيلم الافتتاح فكنا
كلنا موجودين كفريق عمل الفيلم النجوم
جوني ديب والمخرج ماي وان شيء واضح انه
قاعد نرتبط مع السينما العالميه والفرص
قاعد تكبر والحين كل احد يعرف انه السينما
السعوديه صارت ارض خطيبه لهذا المجال
وللسنه الثالثه على تواليه تحضر السعوديه
في مهرجان كان السينمائي في سوق المهرجان
حيث تستقبل الخيمه السعوديه نجوم وصنع
السينما العالميه لتوقيع الاتفاقيات بين
الشركات العالميه المنتجه للسينما وسيتم
تكريم سته فنانات من العالم العربي
وافريقيا باحتفاليه للسينما السعوديه
اول
اذا مشاهدنا في السودان كما نتابع على
العواجل تجدد الاشتباكات في الخرطوم تحليق
لطائرات الجيش وايضا سماع اصوات مضادات
ارضيه هذه التطورات جاءت بعد ان كما ذكرنا
في بدايه النشره كان هناك ظهور لاول مره
خارجي للبرهان على كل الخامسه انتهت نلتقي
على راس الساعه ونشرات جديده مشاهدينا
[موسيقى]
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات